Deben diseñar para los lugares, personas, paisajes
que el muro pone en peligro.
La gente ya se está levantando para esta ocasión,
y mientras que el propósito del muro es mantener a las personas alejadas,
en realidad está uniendo a las personas de maneras realmente notables,
organizando eventos sociales como clases de yoga binacional
a lo largo de la frontera, para unir a las personas a través de la división.
Yo llamo a esto la pose del monumento.
(Risas)
¿Y alguna vez han oído hablar de "wall y ball"?
Es una versión fronteriza de voleibol y se juega desde 1979.
(Risas)
entre la frontera de EE. UU. y México
para celebrar el patrimonio binacional.
Y esto plantea preguntas interesantes,
¿es este juego incluso legal?
¿Golpear una pelota de un lado a otro del el muro constituye un comercio ilegal?
(Risas)
La belleza del voleibol es la que transforma el muro
en nada más que una línea en la arena
negociado por las mentes y cuerpos y espíritus de jugadores de ambos lados.
Y creo que es exactamente este tipo de negociaciones bilaterales
que se necesitan para derribar muros que dividen.
Ahora, lanzar la pelota sobre la pared es una cosa,
pero tirar piedras sobre el muro
ha causado daños a los vehículos de la Patrulla Fronteriza
y ha herido a agentes de la Patrulla Fronteriza,
y la respuesta del lado estadounidense ha sido drástica.
Agentes de la Patrulla Fronteriza han disparado a lo largo del muro,,
matando gente tirando piedras en el lado mexicano.
Y otra respuesta de los agentes de la Patrulla Fronteriza
es erigir los apoyos de béisbol para protegerse a sí mismos y sus vehículos.
Y estos respaldos se convirtieron en un rasgo permanente
en la construcción de nuevos muros.
Y comencé a preguntarme si, como el voleibol,
tal vez el béisbol debería ser una característica permanente en la frontera,
y las paredes podrían comenzar a abrirse,
permitiendo que las comunidades se crucen y jueguen,
y si golpean un jonrón,
tal vez un agente de la Patrulla Fronteriza recoja la pelota y
la devuela al otro lado.
Un agente de la Patrulla Fronteriza compra un raspado, una golosina congelada,
de un vendedor a un par de metros de distancia,
La comida y el dinero se intercambian a través del muro.
Un evento completamente normal hecho ilegal por esa línea dibujada en un mapa
y un par de mm de acero.
Y esta escena me recordó un dicho:
"Si tiene más de lo que necesita, debe construir mesas más largas
Y no muros más altos".
Así que creé este recuerdo para recordar el momento que pudimos compartir
comida y conversación a través de la brecha.
Un columpio permite que uno entre y gire hacia el otro lado
hasta que la gravedad los devuelve a su propio país.
La frontera y el muro fronterizo
es considerado como una especie de teatro político hoy en día,
así que tal vez deberíamos invitar al público a ese teatro,
a un teatro binacional donde la gente puede unirse
con intérpretes, músicos.
Tal vez el muro no sea más que un enorme instrumento,
el xilófono más grande del mundo, y podríamos tocar este muro
con armas de percusión masiva.
(Risas)
Cuando imaginé esta biblioteca binacional,
quería imaginar un espacio donde poder compartir.
libros e información y conocimiento a través de una brecha,
donde la pared no era más que una estantería.
Y quizás la mejor manera de ilustrar la relación mutua que tenemos
con México y EE. UU.
es imaginando un columpio,
donde las acciones de un lado tendrían una consecuencia directa
en lo que sucede en el otro lado,
Porque el borde mismo es tanto un punto de apoyo simbólico como literal
para las relaciones EE. UU. México,
y la construcción de muros entre vecinos corta esas relaciones.
Probablemente recuerden esta cita, "Las buenas cercas hacen buenos vecinos".
A menudo se la considera la moraleja del poema de Robert Frost "Mending Wall".
Pero el poema realmente cuestiona la necesidad de construir muros.
Es un poema sobre la reparación de las relaciones humanas.
Mi línea favorita es la primera:
"Hay algo que no ama una pared".
Porque si hay algo que me queda claro...
No hay dos lados definidos por un muro.
Este es un paisaje, dividido.
Por un lado, podría verse así.
Un hombre está cortando el césped
mientras la pared se cierne en su patio trasero.
Y por otro lado, podría verse así.
La pared es la cuarta pared de la casa de alguien.
Pero la realidad es que el muro atraviesa la vida de las personas.
Se cortando a través de nuestra propiedad privada,
nuestras tierras públicas,
nuestras tierras nativas americanas, nuestras ciudades,
una universidad,
nuestros barrios.
Y no pude evitar preguntarme.
Cómo sería si la pared cortara una casa.
¿Recuerdan esas disparidades entre riqueza y pobreza?
A la derecha está el tamaño promedio de una casa en El Paso, Texas,
y a la izquierda está el tamaño promedio de una casa en Juárez.
Y aquí, la pared corta directamente a través de la mesa de la cocina.
Y aquí, la pared corta a través de la cama en el dormitorio.
Porque quería comunicar cómo el muro no solo está dividiendo lugares,
sino a la gente, está dividiendo a familias.
Y la desafortunada política del muro
es la de hoy, separando a los niños de sus padres.
Puede que estén familiarizados con esta señal de tráfico conocida.
Fue diseñada por el diseñador gráfico John Hood,
un veterano de guerra nativo americano
que trabajaba para el Departamento de Transporte de California.
Y se le encomendó crear una señal para advertir a los automovilistas
de inmigrantes que quedaron varados a lo largo de la carretera
y quienes podría intentar correr a través de la carretera.
Hood relató la situación de los inmigrantes hoy.
A la de los navajos durante la Caminata.
Y esta es realmente una brillante pieza de activismo de diseño.
Y fue muy cuidadoso
al pensar en usar una niña con coletas, por ejemplo,
porque él pensó que es con lo que los automovilistas podrían empatizar más,
y usó la silueta del líder de los derechos civiles César Chávez
para crear la cabeza del padre.
Quería aprovechar el brillo de este signo.
llamar la atención sobre el problema de la separación de niños en la frontera,
e hice un movimiento muy simple.
Di vuelta a las familias para enfrentarlas entre sí.
Y en las últimas semanas,
he tenido la oportunidad de traer esa señal de vuelta a la carretera
para contar una historia,
La historia de las relaciones que deberíamos estar arreglando.
y un recordatorio de que deberíamos estar diseñando
estados reunidos y no estados divididos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)